the right often claims to be all about
free speech and against censorship and
yet Donald Trump is now threatening to
take away media credentials from outlets
that write anything negative about him
yesterday Donald Trump was apparently
watching Fox and Friends on Fox News
obviously they did a story about how 91%
of network news about him is quote
negative now the study is ridiculous
it's from the extremely right-wing Media
Research Center which is run by
outrageous conservative brent bozell
known to some as brent bozo but I call
him brent bozell but okay that's the
source of trumps tweet we can ignore for
now that the media Research Center says
that their goal is to expose and
neutralize the propaganda arm of the
left the national news media let's
pretend that we're saying okay this is
this is the basis for Trump's tweet
Trump then goes to Twitter and says the
fake news is working overtime just
reported that despite the tremendous
successes we're having with the economy
and all things else ninety-one percent
of the network news about me is negative
parentheses fake I'll get back to that
why do we work so hard in working with
the media when it is corrupt take away
credentials so obvious question number
one actually there's a lot of questions
that come from this but one question is
what credentials is Trump talking about
like his Trump saying they won't be
allowed at the White House they won't be
allowed to be part of the press corps or
in the briefing room er they won't be
allowed on Air Force One this is a trend
for Trump because back in October he
threatened to remove the license of NBC
News because of quote fake news that was
coming out of there and Trump has talked
about opening up libel laws to make it
easier to sue media outlets and this is
yet another authoritarian perspective
you shut down news you don't like
whether or not he could do it I don't
really know the answer sort of another
question but it's just ridiculous right
the idea that taking someone's
credentials would stop negative stories
about Trump like just because people
aren't allowed in the press briefing
room if that's what
Trump has in mind they can still write
negative stories about him but I want to
go back to that tweet for a moment
because the other major thing is that
Trump says negative parentheses fake
this is the idea that for Trump anything
negative written about him is by
definition fake which is of course
nonsense and there are people on the
right Trump supporters they're all over
the Internet
they claim to be about free speech they
claim to be about supporting the First
Amendment they're responding to this by
saying good for Trump he's being tough
on the leftist media liars and I went
yesterday out of curious sheera
curiosity I went on to a subreddit that
I won't name it's it's a total breeding
ground for the most extreme reflexive
trumpism I don't want to say the name of
the subreddit I know what it is yeah
some a lot of people in the audience
will know and I saw the following
reactions to news that Trump is
threatening to unlicensed take away the
credentials of certain media quote I
fully support it quote yes yes yes quote
tabloids shouldn't have press
credentials it's pretty obvious quote
yes yes yes I have been saying this for
a very long time the time is now to do
it I thought they supported free speech
and all that stuff I guess all of a
sudden they don't when they think that
it's going to somehow be bad news for
the guy that is their effective lord and
savior this is a real danger because we
know that the entire free speech warrior
thing only applies when it is beneficial
to them and clearly accurate news
reporting is not beneficial to trumpism
and so they want to suppress it I don't
think that Trump would ever follow
through with something like this I think
he just likes those they're
authoritarian talking points may and so
he'll threaten to take away access but
not actually do it so he's feeding into
the trolls there that's all he's doing
I mean you know maybe we shouldn't
underestimate him that's an argument
that the right often makes right when
they say listen it doesn't it doesn't
matter that Trump said he's gonna take
away journalism licenses or whatever
he's not really going to do it he's
using it to coalesce support around an
idea that's what we call lying for
political gain like how that's you're
you're basically defending that he says
things that everyone knows aren't true
or lots of people know aren't true
merely to get votes that's something we
should be against like how do you defend
that okay that's a greater good right
which is to say even if he's lying
overall it's good because he's better
than Killary or something like that and
when he floats the idea of taking away
presidential term limits yeah I think
we're a little bit more protected
against something like that because
you'd have to go through Congress and
amend the Constitution and all that
stuff so I don't take that stuff as
seriously but it seems as if without any
recourse he could cut access for news
outlets like the New York Times and he
saw the others could kick them out of
the press briefing room right like we
know that they could be out of the press
corps could he really suppress their
ability to publish I don't think so
I don't think I don't think he could
what happened to the First Amendment
I guess it's we support it when it's
convenient let's take a break part two
of my interview with Chris Martenson
coming up right after the break today's
episode is made possible in part by
zipper ZPE our banks and other financial
institutions are pretty conservative
when it comes to approving loans and the
major problem with this is not that
they're being cautious but that
immigrants and students and other
disadvantaged groups often don't have
the requisite credit or income to be
approved Zippers goal is to use smart
contract technology and their new
cryptocurrency to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide which would allow
people with no or little credit to
borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
zipper's blockchain zipper's initial
coin offering for their new
cryptocurrency starts April 16th if
you're watching on youtube look in the
description for a link to their website
and links to information about their
airdrop and bounty programs this is not
financial advice and everybody should do
their own research